we're going to
build a modeling ready data set um
for a sales forecasting model uh using
some demo data so if you do have access
to jupiter the place cards have
like a snowflake
so you can use that those credentials to
connect you can actually run the code
that we're going to
step through yourself
um we're we're going to use rosco ql
which is a library that uh
allows you to write python but compiles
to sql
and it pushes all of the um feature
transformations into snowflake so
at the end of the the tutorial you'll
have a
modeling ready data set that's actually
a single uh table in snowflake that you
would then be able to connect a
you know whatever your preferred
modeling library is uh we'll go through
a little bit of the xg boost model at
the end
um not a big crew so just yell out if
you are stuck on anything
i'll kind of go slow at the beginning so
we can make sure everyone's able to keep
up
um
we'll do little checks to make sure that
things are making sense
um
any questions before we jump in
okay
um
first step is uh to get the python
libraries that we need to um
to run the tutorial
rosco ql the one i mentioned is our open
source package
uh that it actually includes the
transformation templates that we're
going to use and it it really uh
emulates pandas in a lot of ways for
like the syntax with which you'll create
the transformations difference being
that they're going to get pushed to
snowflake as sql not run in memory as
python
so you'll see these red
like these blank sections in the code if
you're stepping through the notebook
and so you'll anything that's
highlighted on the slide is the fill in
for like what's missing in the the code
block
so you can kind of
fill those in as you go and then the
code should
run in your notebook
once you kind of populate those values
so
let's check uh
are we good to kind of start running
some of this
okay um
it's probably going to be more uh
interesting for me to show a notebook
then since most of you are not trying to
run the code alongside
um you good with that oh yeah cool
cool let's do that um
so
i'm going to flip over to my notebook
that actually has these values filled in
since you guys aren't writing the code
yourself you'll just be able to
kind of go through this process with me
um and let me make sure this is
beautiful
there we go
cool
okay so um step one install required
packages uh we're going to use like i
said rosco ql for the transformations
and then we've got a couple of libraries
here for the modeling which we'll get to
at the end
and then numpy and pandas for some uh
kind of related steps through the
process
we are working with
the snowflake warehouse so the way that
rosco ql works is it establishes a
connection for you
to your snowflake account
and then it actually allows you to
interact with
the objects in your your snowflake like
database or your entire account
uh directly in kind of this python
notebook
so for instance when i call list tables
and then pass in adventure works that's
saying um it's it's actually running a
query on snowflake and saying in the
adventureworks database
what tables are available and returning
these table names
and then a little bit of metadata about
those tables
so um this is like if your data's in
snowflake and you're used to pulling it
out into pandas before you do all your
feature engineering this is a new
approach you can take that's going to
like let you work directly within stuff
so once we establish uh or once we're
able to
kind of see those tables we're going to
pick a couple to use to start building
features the other important part of
this open source library is the
transforms themselves
um so
a little bit of context here uh as we
print out and kind of list all the
transforms that are available
think of each of these steps as a
a kind of stand-alone operation that
compiles to
a sql query
that would then be run in snowflake so
for instance let's take then
bin is a
jinja sql template that is available in
the github repo
um which i'll show you just so you kind
of
uh
understand the concept here
and what rosco ql is actually doing when
you call a bin uh transform is it's
hydrating this sql query
so this is a kind of pre-written
query that does binning on a column in
snowflake
and you can see some of the
variables here those are the things
we're actually going to set using rascal
ql
it'll compile like render that to sql
and then push that to snowflake
so just so you know like kind of what's
happening as we step through this code
that we're essentially
building these chains of many sql
transformations
uh does that make sense any questions so
far okay
cool
um and then there's always a fallback
which is uh like you know maybe the
specific thing you're trying to do
is not available in a transform template
there's one called apply which just
applies custom sql so you can definitely
uh include that in your chain as you're
going
okay let's start with
kind of one of the core tables that
we're going to build features out of so
this is a
fact internet sales table
this data set it's a demo data set for a
retailer so this is think of this as
like uh
they're selling i think it's bike parts
online
um and these are you know records of
each of their sales
rosco ql once you assign a variable to
that data set
you can then kind of interact with that
variable and and like run python
functions that uh trigger you know sql
interaction with your with your
snowflake account
so for instance dot preview called on a
rosco data set
returns a 10 row pandas data frame so
it's just saying select top 10 from that
table so you can kind of see
and start interacting with you know
columns and values just to get a sense
of what's contained in that data
so
now we're going to run our first
transformation
it's a really simple transformation
because it's just an order uh ordering
the table just to allow us to better
kind of inspect this um this fact table
you can kind of see the syntax here so
we call
dot order against the rql dataset object
that we established above
and then the order by is a like a
diction uh yeah dictionary where you can
set ascending or descending in the
specific columns
so if if you worked with pandas like
this probably looks pretty familiar um i
don't think it
takes the order by and pandas takes a
dick but you can kind of picture how it
um how it's very similar in syntax
no um good question this is actually
compiling sql and running in snowflake
exactly yes
um
so each time we uh build a or like add a
transformation to our sql chain uh
we can then call dot preview on it which
will run in uh that query and then
select top ten against it to pull that
back but you're just seeing those ten
rows so the underlying table here could
be
a billion raise right and we're if we're
working in um jupiter like it's not
pouring all that into memory
um
this is a way so that preview object you
get back is a
first class like panda's data frame so
you can call things like dot columns on
it uh just to further inspect
and all we're doing here is just finding
the right column names for once we go
into the future engineering steps so the
one we're kind of highlighting here is
promotion key
as being important as we're going to
build out a sales forecast
okay um let's start doing some joining
so
this is um where a lot of the heavy
lifting starts
uh first we're going to
we're now working with the promotion
table which is is related to the
fact internet sales table because each
transaction is tagged with a promotion
key if it had a promotion on it
so now we want to actually join those
two together so we can kind of see the
sales and the promotion side by side
this step will run a drop columns so
we're going to kind of subset the table
down to just the columns that we care
about
and then
you get a quick preview here of like how
much is each promotion
discounting the the sale
and then what you can see is see how we
assigned the result of that
transformation to this new variable
reduce promo
that can now be joined
with the internet sales table and you
can think of that reduce promo as
like a almost like a draft data set
because it only exists in the context of
this notebook right now but as we get
further down you'll see how you can
actually persist that in snowflake as a
table or view
if you want to make that like permanent
you know outside of the sequence that
we're going through yes
yeah yeah exactly so it's it's in memory
but the data's not in memory
so
if i actually like print what that is
it's a um
the primitive we call as a sql chain
it's like
a
representation of mult you know one or
more sql steps that's being built up as
we're going through this notebook
so it's not actually a
it's like a
query that you can run to get data but
it's not data in memory does that make
sense
exactly
that's right um
and yeah somewhere in here i'll start
printing sql i think and we can kind of
start to inspect that but each of these
sql chains can be rendered as
a table
or a view so you can kind of like export
this into sql logic at any point
okay so uh you can see the joint syntax
pretty straightforward if you've done
joining before kind of your standard
stuff like what are you joining with
what's the sql join type and then on
what columns do you want to join
um
this is not happy because i probably did
something on the border
um
[Music]
i said i'm not sure what it's mad about
but
so part of like working in this
sequential way is that um
these variables become
the
the way that you're expressing your
chain and python your chain of sql
um
must have known the columns
anyway um i think i have it already run
somewhere
um sorry bear with us
oh we don't have the answer key
yeah a quick shout out if you like to on
github and star things this is a great
thing to start
um
it's especially awesome when it works
this one
okay
yeah cool
all right
so here's the step we're on which we
oh did i not comment out this
yep
oh
i was gonna
see if i can change it without
find out
that's correct
yeah i wanted to show
where we start rendering sql because
then it's it all starts to sort of make
sense
um how this all ties together
so
there's multiple ways you can save this
object um
so you can actually create a new table
and the full chain of sql that you've
been building up as you go through these
transformations can be embedded in like
a creator place view as statement
um and then that's that would render the
entire uh sql chain and it does it as
ctes
like
table expressions
it will yeah if you do it as a view
that's the benefit right is your um
any time you hit that view you're going
to get a live uh look at the underlying
feature values if you rendered it as a
table
like a materialized table then you'd
have to refresh it
and then let me just show
so we have
some pretty good docs that will also
help if you try to use this at home
um one of the
i just wanted you to be able to see the
different options
for how you render the sequel
which all right
so um oh that's what i did wrong
parentheses um
by default uh you get to choose your
render method like i said um
it's going to wrap all of this logic in
uh in that kind of ct structure so it'll
do with you know creator replace as
and then
you can also export this to dbt so if
you think of you're building up a sql
chain
um going through this kind of process of
feature engineering let's say it had 15
steps in it
at the end you may want to save that as
a dbt model
so that that the table that you want to
refresh could be refreshed
and so this makes it really easy to do
that because
you can run two underscore dvt on any
sql chain and that's going to create all
the
kind of file artifacts that bbt needs to
treat that as a model that you've just
built
does that make sense
okay
good um okay let's get back in
to
the flow so part of the feature
engineering that we're doing we're
building up
the data set for the weekly sales
forecast so we're going to start
creating weekly data by running a date
trunk on the order date
and then
um you can see kind of calling the date
trump function here
that it tells the date trunk take the
order date and pull out the week part of
that uh so that'll default to like first
day of the week being
sunday and then
once you do that you can actually start
aggregating
so
um this kind of block of code shows
doing two things it runs the date trunk
and then it calls the aggregate in a
chain so if you're familiar with pandas
chaining of functions
this package kind of supports the same
syntax
and you can see in the aggregate you
pass a group by list which are the
columns that you want to group by and
then you can aggregate
other columns like within multiple ways
with this kind of syntax where you pass
the
the key is the column name and then the
value is a list of aggregation types
that you want to run on that column
so this is one of my favorites for
feature engineering because
obviously we do a lot of aggregation but
like
doing this in sql is kind of a mess
so this makes it a lot more succinct the
other cool thing we did is we just added
a couple more aggregation types to this
transform one of them is called entropy
which is a really cool way to
aggregate a categorical uh column
and it looks for variability across the
values in that column
um it's almost like a
a count distinct um
sort of like a weighted count distinct
is how i think about it so if you
had two um columns and one had
uh 20 values in it that were all the
same and then a single value that was
different and you're on account distinct
on that you get a two back right it has
two unique values but
really it's heavily weighted toward one
of them so entropy kind of accounts for
that reason uh and if you want to
see some more detail on that it's in the
um
the nice part about these is you can
always go to the source code
in this uh in these transforms
which is complicated but is still good
to kind of be able to unpack so
you can always go into the aggregate and
you could say
um i want the snowflake
aggregate template and you can see
exactly how it's computing the entropy
um the actual math is down here it runs
uh
this um it's like a logarithmic way to
weight the values in the column
so just a shout out that um things like
this suck to do in sql so it's a lot
better if you have a template that you
can just run versus trying to type that
every time
when you're
wanting to run that aggregation
so it only
compiles the sql right now um which
has a limitation right because some
workloads need like a python like a
looping approach
um
that's uh something that we're excited
for
um snowflake to kind of help with with
the the python udfs so once they go
public pre public preview on python
udfs then we're going to add support
here to let you push in python function
and call it through the same
right
yeah so great question um if you saw
when i went into
the um
like any
transform actually my favorite is uh
date trunk
yeah so date trunk is different in like
every sql syntax because it's just a
pain like that so um we have been
building up
uh over time support for more um
more sql syntaxes everyone says they're
antsy but like they all still disagree
right
um so right now we have three supported
snowflake postgres and bigquery um
and there's definitely slight
differences like if you look at
the bigquery date trunk it has like a
known function for that
whereas i think the postgres one you
have to run an extract on it
uh
no it wasn't this one it must win the
date part but um yeah there's definitely
some slight differences we're accounting
for that and how we build the templates
yeah so and and as we continue to expand
obviously if you are passionate about
that problem you can work on it too
because it's open source but uh i'm
guessing we'll be doing a lot of the
heavy lifting there and continuing to
support more
sql synthesis
we've added
post questions big query over the last
two weeks since we launched it to the uh
officially three weeks ago and then i
think this week my sequel's getting
added to like there's more databases
being
exported soon and we've got a bunch of
other
issues
to kind of show but one that in
particular
having someone you know if you want
something
yeah we're upvoting with uh thumbs right
now i guess so
good way to track what people are
looking for
um the other part so as we get into more
like true feature engineering uh this is
a forecast model that we're working
toward as i mentioned at the beginning
in building that up you end up doing a
lot of window functions
which again fit the bill for me of
things i don't want to write in sql
and so
the lag transformation there's a time
series aggregate transformation which
will create
aggregates over like moving windows
those templates i think are some of the
most useful that the package has
and it allows you to generate a lot of
features really quickly so you can see
how this one is
it's taking a subset of the columns in
the data set
and it's taking a um a list of amounts
uh that that you want to lag by so since
we're with weekly data this does a
one week two week three weekend and
twelve weeks and um
when you run this
it's going to create
those lags for every column so you're
really quickly here generating
what probably
50 features or something
um out of those those lags
and uh
those all show up as like windowed
functions in the the raw sql um but just
templated so it makes it kind of easy
so yeah
any um
any sort of feature generation you're
trying to do at scale um
to kind of then run some future
importance on it and get to like a
reduced set of features this can make
that a lot easier
similarly with moving average again
looking at these windows and looking at
how
sales activity in the past can predict
you know future demand um that's the
intent of these features like if you
think of what a 12-week lag on
order quantity is doing it's saying
12 weeks ago how much demand was there
for this specific product and then you
know in the model when we fit the
algorithm we're thinking that that's
going to be predictive of you know
future future demand
so more features in that vein
that's also what we're building with
moving average
now we're at the point where we actually
have a data set that we want to save in
in snowflake
benefit here is obviously if you're
using a modeling tool that's connected
to your snowflake you know if you aren't
writing your modeling code just in
python
this was sort of compatible with that
because once you create that view you
can connect to it with something like a
data robot
to to build your model or you could
obviously
go into our next step and
kind of create the final modeling data
and fit the model in python
uh yes
yeah right now it's uh very user driven
like it doesn't magically generate
features for you
um we do have
on our roadmap a concept of
we call it accelerators what it means is
basically it does some of that feature
generation for you using this as the
underlying
kind of language
and
just based on the model type you're
building so if you're doing a time
series forecast it generates a lot of
window uh
look back features but but yeah that is
something that's on our roadmap
it's live in our enterprise product but
we
um this uh open source product kind of
stands on its own and so uh
it's extra work to add it here but we
want to
other questions
okay let's go to the fun part um
this code now transitions into sort of
what i would call like final uh
feature prep for for a specific type of
model
um so
we actually use the lag transform to
create the target variable because what
it's going to do there is shift
all of the predictors
essentially like
avoid leakage by shifting the the target
one week forward so we make sure that
we're trying to predict next week's
sales
using lag is kind of a cool way to do
that
and then uh
other thing you can do here which again
is not typically done in sql but it's
really nice when you do it is uh
is encoding so we have a number of
encoding transform templates in this
library um one hot in code target and
label or
three of those
this one uses a target encoding
which
is kind of a cool one i mean they're all
sort of useful but uh obviously a lot of
algorithms don't support inputting
categorical uh features directly so by
encoding those you get a numerical
feature that you can actually use in
that prediction
this is a fun one so uh depending on
your data quality
you may have to do some imputing
at the end
and one way to do that because of the
specific model
approach that this this tutorial takes
um we impute with a really large outlier
and because it's a tree based model that
has the effect of kind of filtering and
sort of throwing out the uh the areas
where there's missing values um
so this one's sort of algorithm specific
of how you would want to handle the
imputation but the package has a nice
sort of flexible impute transform which
will find all the rows with missing
values and then impute those missing
values with the values passed in this
kind of dictionary structure
uh and then i think this is our last
transform the train test split
um so again something you probably
usually do in scikit-learn uh do this
also adds it as a column in sql so if
you look at the end here it creates a
trained test split labeling
so and it does that using a random
sample strategy so you can put in the
percent of the the rows that you want to
use for training
it also supports a order by first sort
of a time aware train test split
and then it will output a column that
labels each row whether it's in the
train set or the test set
and now we're at the point where we have
a final modeling data set we can
actually save into snowflake as a view
and start modeling
yeah thanks
um
awesome so
i forget okay yeah so it uses a xg boost
model here to
actually make the prediction um this
kind of final step is where you do have
to actually extract the data from
snowflake so we're at that point where
we're kind of past what we can do in sql
right as we want to go train this model
so this package does have a convenience
method for that you can call 2df on any
rql data set
and it'll extract that into a pandas
data frame
so like all that compute until this
point has been happening in snowflake
but now this is
the time where we're actually going to
pull it out into the notebook to do
modeling and the nice part there is like
think of all the aggregation that we've
done
data sizes uh at this final feature
kind of step or much smaller than it
would have been
if we had exported the whole base
stainless steel
into python
and uh basically just uses the train
test split to create the two different
data frames just one for the train and
one for the test set and then it
actually fits the model
the xg boost model on
the train set
and it goes through a bit of kind of
standard
model evaluation
and then shows you how to actually make
a new prediction
using data in snowflake
to
kind of pull like a relevant row or set
of rows that might represent the values
that you're trying to predict into the
near future
uh make a prediction
and
um then you get you have an actual model
that's in
i don't know pseudo production at that
point where you could make recurring
predictions of people
and that is